it's great to welcome to the program
today Ben Burgess who's April Asif II
professor at Georgia State University
University perimeter college and author
of the book give them an argument logic
for the left which I'm very very
interested to talk about been really
great to have you on you know thanks for
having me
so before we get into like the material
you and I have both appeared on the
Jesse Lee Peterson show and I've told my
audience ma I don't really take it super
seriously I think it's sort of like an
avant-garde performance art sort of
thing what what was your approach when
you were invited like I'm guessing you
were familiar with the types of
interviews he does uh actually I've got
to say I really was not okay so so his
his producer contacted me he was a
little bit vague about what this was but
I was like yeah sure whatever I'll do it
and then like I kind of looked him up on
Wikipedia it's like okay this is gonna
be a hostile interview you know kind of
got a sense of what the guys were used
were yeah but you know whatever I'm game
I've done that and I mean I think it was
probably much funnier because I really
didn't know what I was getting into but
you know but whatever like you know like
I said it's not the most it's not the
most serious thing and you know and I
think it makes for some good clips yeah
I mean so it kind of leads into what I
want to talk with you about because in
in the book and in general you talk
about the way that the left Canon should
use logic and reasoning and this is very
prevalent in online discussions where
also the format of the discussion can be
very limiting in terms of you know what
what the strategies are that can be
employed successfully what is I mean you
can't like if you go to Jesse Lee
Peterson and try to just do logic and
say hold you know like I do to hold on
Jesse you're saying eh now you're saying
the opposite of a I don't even know what
your position is you're misstating my
position it's sort of like a black hole
of logic so to speak so you think that a
lot of the ideas of how the left should
debate are context dependent oh
absolutely yeah I mean something that I
do try to emphasize a few times in the
book is that I'm not recommending that
anybody give an unlimited amount of
their time to
and energy to like anybody who wants to
argue about anything ever I think that
you need to be selective and strategic
about it and I'm not sure that there is
a good way for example to to go on the
Jesse Lee Peterson show at least if your
goals or anything except for to you know
have kind of like you know something
that like well if you know people will
find amusing later when they watch it
you know so I think that the reasons
that are that it's important to be
better at reasoning and and to make more
explicit arguments for left positions
and to like spend more time taking apart
you know bad right-wing arguments don't
necessarily translate it to say that you
should like engage with any particular
forum in which the opportunity to to do
that do that arises because you know
obviously you know if if somebody you
know if you have somebody who just wants
to ask you loaded questions and then
yell at you for not giving yes we go
ahead sirs you know there is no amount
of like showing why he's using bad
reasoning that's gonna make much of a
dent in that situation is there any
particular area of focus in terms of
topics where you see that the left is
not arguing in what you would identify
is the most logically well reasoned and
effective way whether it's a particular
social issue or GOP I mean just anything
is look we're what would be exhibit a in
your mind of where we should be looking
to what not to do yeah sure so so I
think that one thing that that we do a
lot of that we should you know that we
should not do is just kind of generally
speaking when encountering you know
conservative or libertarian arguments
kind of you know making fun of them and
then leave it at that right you know
that they have that just sort of doing
the mockery but not actually ever
explain getting around to explaining
what's wrong with the argument which is
a bad move not just for some like
high-minded reason of principle but
because it gives me gifts fence sitters
the understandable impression that you
don't really have a good
response to the argument and so I guess
one one small example is when people are
talking about about trans rights and you
know and and affirming you know gender
identities of trans people very often I
see people using a pretty bad argument
for that which is to sort of try to deny
that there's an underlying distinction
about biological sex I don't think
that's a good move because I think that
you know in any other context we would
cry out quite rightly say that the mere
fact that like there are they're
ambiguous cases between two categories
doesn't mean that there's no real
underlying distinction between the
categories I think a much better way of
arguing for the same conclusions as far
as rights and dignity for trans people
and calling people whatever pronouns
they want to be called as a matter of
basic human decency is to say that there
are multiple ways of using words like
man and woman and sure one of them might
track biological sex another might track
you know gender identity and gender
expression and that it's a matter of
basic human decency to use the latter
and in most contexts yeah I feel like
it's interesting you bring that one up
because I as someone obviously staunchly
on the left who wants to do everything I
can to support just treating everybody
decently and making sure that under the
law people aren't you know all of the
stuff that would fall under that I feel
that I tread carefully when I even want
to talk about how we are talking about
that issue because rightly or wrongly I
worry that if I say the wrong thing I'm
going to trigger a backlash where the
black backlash itself becomes the focus
which is not at all my goal if that
makes sense yeah absolutely
let's talk a little bit about when it
comes to I've talked before about how I
think on some issues the right has a
sort of structural advantage that aligns
with their positions politically and
I'll give two examples to get what your
thoughts on it
one is abortion the other is taxation
the right has a structural advantage
when talking about abortion for example
because their position is so simple and
cut-and-dry that the left can't possibly
oppose it with something as pithy and
concise wishes abortions murder and
therefore that it is wrong period and of
course the position on the left is not
the opposite of that it's not abortions
great and let's have more of them it's a
nuanced position on taxation on one
position on the right is it's my money I
earned it I should get to keep as much
of it as whatever and then they will
usually draw the line somewhere and of
course the position on the left is not
the opposite of no the government should
get all your money it's a nuanced
position that requires understanding
what are we trying to fund what is our
responsibility to society do you see
that as a structural advantage for the
right is question one in question two is
what can we on the Left have as a tool
to counteract it yeah so I think that
that definitely gives them an advantage
certainly when you're pushing back
against those things we can't push back
against them by say and you know that
you know we think I'd be fine if the
taxation rate for middle income people
was 100 percent or that you know be fine
to have an abortion you know five
minutes before the delivery day you know
would have happened anyway but we have
to you know we have to impose some
nuance there in fact actually ironically
I think in the abortion case the right
is making the same mistake that
well-intentioned people on the Left
often make in the case I've just
described which is to say well alright
you have two categories it's ambiguous
when you go from one to the other
because you know you have a sort of
series of stages where you're slowly
approaching the distinction and it's not
clear where the sharp cutoff point is
right where you go from a mindless
collection of cells to something that
should clearly have whatever moral
rights a human baby has therefore
because we're not sure where the cutoff
point is there you know there just isn't
a real distinction or you know it must
be the same thing all along which is the
continuum fallacy which is again the
mistake I think some of us are making in
other contexts oh that's nothing can you
so I've talked that one way I fought
against the continuum fallacy is by
saying listen you set a speed limit at
35 miles per hour
you're not saying 37 is always unsafe
and you're not saying that sometimes if
the conditions are poor you don't have
to go much slower the fact that one line
doesn't apply exactly in all cases
doesn't mean we don't have to set the
line somewhere as a society I've been
trying to use some version of that but
can you can you talk about where else
the left is incorrectly relying on the
continuum fallacy because that's
interesting to me yeah so there's sort
of arguments that deny biological sex I
think of the most obvious examples of
the left doing it I think it's certainly
easy to come up with examples where I
think the right is guilty of this the
abortion of example is one of them
another one is the response that a lot
of people had to receipt it to leave
when she said that well okay the minimum
wage when you know the sort of fight
4:15 movement started in like 2012 $15
made sense but now especially given how
long it would take to get any of this
legislation fully into place the
reasonable range would be more like 18
to 20 and a lot of right-wingers jumped
on that they're like oh well 20 why not
25 why not 50 why not a thousand dollars
an hour and like the speed limit case
you could say well hold on just because
there's some ambiguity right just
because okay 18 is probably fine 19 or
20 is probably fine that doesn't mean
that you know and it's a little unclear
when you cross the line to what would be
unreasonable and unworkable that doesn't
mean that there isn't a real distinction
there that $1,000 would be fine right
if we change the speed limit to 36 miles
an hour that would probably be fine
but obviously that's different from you
know just have it in Auto Bahn where you
can go as fast as you want or you don't
have the speed limit be 100 miles an
hour which would be incredibly dangerous
so so yeah and I think that you could
also just use the sort of common sense
example start with somebody who's
completely bald out of hair - their head
out of hair at a hair until they're like
Fabio at some point they stop being bald
we can't tell exactly when that is but
it's obviously a logical mistake to say
therefore there just is no distinction
between being bald and being not bald
well this gets to maybe one of the most
interesting broader questions around are
that I have with politics which is that
I've been critical in some ways of the
movements that are all about
establishing their set of principles and
guidelines and in a vacuum staking out
what their ideology is because I think
that there's two risks to that one risk
is you definitely when arguing run the
risk of getting pulled into what I call
these philosophical black holes that
ultimately solve no real problems and
more importantly I think the difficult
work is in actually figuring out what
balance of our principles should be
applied in the real world to solve
problems we're facing and I think that
sometimes the the overwhelming focus
merely on abstract principles actually
prevents us from solving real world
issues do you think that that is a
concern and how do you balance that
between that and pragmatics yeah well so
I think this is actually one of the
important themes of the book which is
that when we talk about like kind of
taking logic and you know back to the
left from the sort of you know
right-wing libertarian types who like
love to go on and on about how they love
fat logic facts and reason kind of use
these phrases
yeah almost like magical incantations
you know that means two things one of
them is you know making better you know
showing what's wrong with those people's
arguments and make it arguments for
better positions but the other one which
is even more important is taken back the
sort of way that we're going about it
from them right so one thing that's
incredibly damaging about these guys is
that they've convinced so many people
that carried about logic and reasoning
means like having like three like first
principles and just extrapolating
everything from that but of course
that's not good reasoning right you know
like you have to take in all sorts of
other things into account you know if
you start with the first principle then
you run into problems you should go back
through line board and see if your
principle isn't great and so I did I
think a lot of this does take new ones I
think I get what you're saying about
pragmatics that you know it could be
that you know if we're just you know
doing nuance nuance nuance all the time
then you're sort of going to lose the
political war the people who have simple
and easily understood ideas
and so I think there's a balance there
between on the one hand showing that we
can make you know good nuanced critiques
of those people's ideas which for
anybody who just you know might think
that we don't have a good answer or
might be sort of taken in by those ideas
who's like intellectually sincere that
might help them but at the same time we
can put forward counter narratives that
aren't just necessarily nuanced nuanced
new ones all the time like you know we
care you know like a right to abortion
is important because people should have
a right to control their own bodies you
know really like redistribute taxation
is good you know because a fair society
is you know is more equal and really
meaningfully more free for most people
and you know we can kind of put forward
those counter narratives without falling
into being totally simplistic about them
and saying that like you know well the
right to bodily autonomy is so important
that you know that if you were gonna
give birth on Tuesday you can have an
abortion on Monday right you know that
we don't have to you know we don't have
to sort of stick to our guns like a
libertarian who's arguing themselves to
the point of like denying age of consent
laws but we could still but we could
still put forward reasonable clearly
understood principles in a sense we need
to have a variety of tools at our
disposal and know in what proportion
different tools should be applied to
particular jobs I guess is the way that
I would sort of sum it up and a lot of
these tools are in Ben's book give them
an argument logic for the left Ben
Burgess is a philosophy professor at
Georgia State University perimeter
college I I think I did a better job
saying all the words that time Ben I
really appreciate your time and it's
been so great having you on all right
thank you so much